ces 16 millions d'étrangers les français
les côtoient sans déplaisir en toute
quiétude
ce sont des touristes
mais ces quatre millions d'étrangers qui
viennent en france pour travailler et
qu'on ne rencontre plus au pied de la
tour eiffel mais plutôt à 6 heures du
matin dans le métro ou en train de
balayer les rues les voit-on de la même
manière
s'inquiétant de leur vie
quelles sont leurs problèmes essentiels
et quotidien nous avons tenté de le
savoir à travers cinq familles monsieur
et madame bénéteau sont espagnols ils
ont deux fils éric et josé
monsieur et madame youssef sont
algériens ils ont deux enfants halim et
nadia monsieur et madame cocar son
yougoslave ils ont une fille cathy
madame ces guérillas et portugaise elle
a un fils maurice
monsieur et madame diaby sont sénégalais
ils ont un petit garçon sans qu aucune
des cinq familles que nous avons
interrogés ne prétend refléter dans son
intégralité l'opinion et la façon de
vivre de ses compatriotes mais la
simplicité et la sincérité de leurs
réponses en même temps que la grande
pudeur avec laquelle ces hommes de ces
femmes nous ont parlé de ce qui peut les
blesser directement ou à travers leurs
enfants en un mot atteindre leur dignité
ne peut laisser personne indifférent
[Musique]
c'est en france depuis combien de temps
madame bénéteau et plus
à
164 real qu'un fonds se sentent pas
votre marié vous vous êtes venus
ensemble non séparément
et marié un terrain très 1,62 et
je suis venu 63 c'est un nom aussi
connaissait pas et ça fait c'est pas en
un an est telle que j'étais en france ce
canton s'étaient mariés
après évidemment si la famille est
arrivé et
on est là
à
m
pour vos enfants tout s'est toujours
bien passé jamais de problèmes à l'école
je crois plus maintenant mais au début
oui le comprenez que le petit a commencé
à aller à la grande colère passée
eric est
oui mais vraiment des problèmes il resté
seul dans un coin
sans jouer les autres voulaient pas
jouer avec eux ça ça m'a fait beaucoup
de la cour il vous la raconter oui
qu'est ce qui s'était passé qu'est ce
qu'on avait dit
vous élisez qui vous ne voulez pas jouer
avec lui que le désert espagnol tout ça
est vraiment sa cité
c'est un peu ennuyeux
[Musique]
le religieux a beaucoup d'importance
pour vous bien sûr oui très pratiquants
oui j'ai eu un moment que je croyais moi
ma faim non j'ai continué à y croire
vous avez eu du mal à trouver du travail
ne parlons pas de français oui oui c'est
à dire qui est au début je travaillais
avec l'espagnol y avait pas problème
mais après que je les ai quittés pour
nous marier que toujours me suis marié
j'ai eu vraiment des problèmes parce que
je parlais pas un mot je n'avais pas les
papiers je ne vais je n'avais pas les
cartels travail ni rien alors si tu à ce
moment là que je vais vraiment des
problèmes comment vous les avez surmonté
ses problèmes mais c'est à dire que les
enfants
on a cherché on a essayé de chercher à
la loge
et j'avais évidemment comme je n'avais
pas la carte et travail personnel
voulait nous prend dernier personne nous
faisait confiance ce qu'évidemment je
n'avais pas aucun papier j'avais que les
bassins par seydou et plus après
je travaillais ici dans cette maison et
je connus par assa enfin de la concierge
qui devait parti que fait votre mari
madame travaille chez citroën
garder un bébé je crois oui
c'est à dire que sa mère travaille et
son grand-père le gard les joueurs m'ont
donné le biberon et changer je suis
comme ça
est ce que
monsieur bénéteau pas l'éducation de vos
enfants
dépend ça dépendra fatigue des mois vous
allez 2d très fatigué qu'est ce que vous
faites comme horaire les travailleurs
équipes du matin et comme recherche isr
si j'avais mis une prochaine l'après
midi est la question qui est très bel
après midi et pour magna trajet fini
à minuit
il n'a pas acheté quoi vous avez choisi
la france
pas je vous les sortez de chez nous
s'était déroulé sortie de l'espagne pas
pourquoi
parce que je voulais
si vous voulez visiter à notre pays
enfin sa voie qu'est ce qui avait
d'ailleurs quoi il ya vingt ans que ce
en france et pourquoi pourquoi vous avez
avec votre famille oui je suis venu avec
mes pas mes parents va pas envoyer avant
le travail en france et ont failli après
nous a fait venir
pour
pour paru je ne sais même pas pourquoi
j'ai venu comme ça va là et je ne trouve
pas mal ici
ces petits vous n'avez que deux pièces
mais je ne change pas pour un autre même
qui soit 4 pièces peu beaucoup voire
tout ce que j'avais sont bien ici à
cause de quoi elle pense que les gens
sont vraiment très gentils tout le monde
je n'ai pas eu des problèmes des cris je
suis là
monsieur n'était ce qu'un mari espagnol
aide sa femme dans les travaux ménagers
ah oui et oui partout pareil comme en
français mais
qui perd oui
mais combien tu habitais vu dans cette
cité hlm il ya deux ans
mais vous faites quoi en ce moment vous
êtes dans une école maternelle oui
qu'est-ce qui vous fait il bien sûr que
des enfants d'ailleurs j'aime tellement
les enfants je suis très heureux d'être
près d'eux et je crois si ghost
l'ajustement d'ailleurs autant que des
français autant de petites algérienne
ils sont très malheureuse affaire est
certaine kipré malheureuse quoi ils ont
besoin de notre amour en fait quand ils
ont besoin de notre
madame la directrice il ya longtemps que
je vais madame youssef ça votre corps
moi je suis arrivé jeudi à elle accouche
vivre ll est bien vitrine bien sa vie en
est les dames de service c'est à dire
que ce qu'il est petit on prend des
points hier
mon passage en valais romand la cantine
et puis mais là
vous allez la garder avec vous même
dépend pas de moi vous allez rester dans
cette école non je resterai pour un mois
parce que j'ai rien et j'ai pas trop
tracé dans un poste
je vous demandais si c'est difficile de
renoncer aux coutumes de son pays de
devenir une véritable européenne comme
vous l'avez c'est difficile on aura
toujours quelque chose moi je crois
qu'on peut pas ce que vous avez repris
certaines notions d'éducation que votre
maman vous avez les tout est ce qu'il le
raconte des légendes est à dire moment
comme elle ne cause pas beaucoup bien
sûr enfin la rive table sinon mais papa
oui continuez à vous sentir algérienne
oui
votre mari vous l'avez connu en france
sauvée laurie bei cousins français
je crois non pourquoi parce que question
de parents et sa mort a posé beaucoup de
problèmes après j'aurais plus peur soit
pour moi j'ai des verts
il ya des moments oui j'ai vu que des
fois ils ont besoin de causes diverses
et par contre ils feront une bêtise je
le puis comprendre gentiment ci
comprennent pas en ce moment une bonne
fessée je répèterai pas la 3d repose
aller
pour les devoirs vous arrivez à les
suivre un petit peu quand même ou du but
oui la petite wii mais le garçon
maintenant plutôt je crois c'est lui qui
souffre d'aucune des caisses que vient
faire écho aujourd'hui
madame
les calculs et géographie ça marche bien
oui j'ai des devoirs à faire pour ce
soir oui
je suis déjà ce que tu veux faire quand
tu seras grand oui qu'est-ce que c'est
un docteur j'vais te dire j'ai bien
travaillé m'a bien aujourd'hui oui
qu'est ce que tu as appris à l'école
valérie sur la ville de bagnères
mais là et c'est aujourd'hui que j'ai
moi même rires non
mais qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça aurait
appelé en décembre
2008 le chef de la cia et loire
joue avec magna fait l'école maurice
aujourd'hui
avec nani vous lui apprenez à parler en
français ou dans votre dans votre langue
je
s'il a une liste il parle avec notamment
français mais ici le palam
il va à l'école en france
péter luisi cela
qu'est ce qu'il fait votre mari comme
travail madame et les mouleurs le métier
effet l'art la feuille d'or enfin c'est
le nom je crois qu'ils font des petits
orge enfin de les glaces et tout ça que
vraiment que c'est très très jolie
l'artisanat pour voir la wii et on fait
que mal malheureusement son travail
enfin ils ont fait faillite son patron
il était obligé bien sûr il est resté
pendant un an sans travail
et après ils apprendre et la plus
blanche isri qui suspend son petit lit
tout mais la leur et se défend pas mal
vous avez d'embûches lyocell de vous
occuper un petit peu d'éducation de vos
enfants je travaille loin ça pensant
maxence jeu puis 60 km à l'est 60 kg
mettant autour ça me fait 120 km aller
retour
et je rentre un peu tard le soir vers 7h
7h30
c'est bien quand on rentre à 7h30 à tous
les enfants s'en sentent déjà bhl et des
fois quand j ai franchement quand j'ai
le temps
je suis par tous les moyens pour l'aider
et je sacrifie tout mon tendre pour eux
pour aider mes enfants vous des échanges
avec lui sur le plan de la vie sociale
vous intéressez vous à tout ça oui
mais comme je dis que je ne sais pas
assez ce truc pour ça je cherche pas
fait je voudrais bien voyez-vous
quelqu'un qui me fait comprendre si vous
vous sentez bien en france
merci oui
je peux pas dire le contraire
[Musique]
vous occuper de votre classe plus
spécifiquement des enfants a réadapté je
crois ce que tous les enfants sont aussi
bien intégrés et que des petits youssef
ces petits algériens que nous venons de
voir non non c'est vraiment une minorité
je crois que c'est très rare et en
général
la majorité des enfants immigrés ont des
problèmes sur le plan d'adaptation
scolaire et en particulier enfin au
moins sur le groupe les enfants de
travailleurs algériens et comment
expliquez vous ça
moi je crois qu'il ya déjà une
explication
c'est les conditions de vie qu'ils enfin
qu'ils subissent tout même en france
encore que de plus en plus de
travailleurs immigrés sont engagés dans
des cités mais l'adaptation se fait pas
si facilement et en particulier au
niveau des enfants des bidonvilles ont
disparu quand même oui enfin le
bidonville en tant que tel n'existe plus
mais ayant encore beaucoup de secteurs
où il ya des taudis enfin en particulier
dans le quartier on retrouve encore des
logements insalubres ou des logements
très petit dans lesquels s'entassent
une famille immigrée à très forte
densité enfin en général et beaucoup de
familles nombreuses
quelles solutions envisagez vous
fallait solution je crois
qu'actuellement
telles que les choses sont aussi bien
par rapport à l'école que
la situation on pense aussi à les
travailleurs immigrés ont on arrive à
aguerrir un petit peu à soigner des
plaies on aide un enfant à s'en sortir
on est des gens à s'en sortir mais
la solution je crois que c'est un
problème de structure
on vous organisez-vous dre cathy qui
s'en occupe la journée qui la gare ben
maintenant c'est l'école elle va à
l'école qu'elle était petite elle était
chez une nourrice était chez une dame
qui gardait la jaune et c'est beaucoup
plus facile parce que elle pas à l'école
puis ça coûte beaucoup moins cher je
suis plutôt inquiet
[Applaudissements]
vous savez nous sommes prêtes à porter
c'est très différent d'avec ce que vous
avez appris que vous avez les études
pour faire quoi dans votre pays j'ai
fini économie et finance et en france
parce que je travaille qu'est ce que je
veux c'est à dire je trouvais ça
que je trouve que c'est pas mal pour une
femme surtout quand on peut se rhabiller
peut-être avec un prix qui est
raisonnable en quoi consiste votre
travail dans cet atelier
surtout que je fais la boutonnière sur
la machine
du tout du tout du tout par amour
pansement rien et passe un moment non
pas du tout si je serai bien parler
comme cela en france
j'aurais travaillé aussi tôt
c'est imposerait où j'allais beaucoup de
france j'allais beaucoup d'écrivains
français
j'avais beaucoup de départs et je vois
dans mon rêve paris par les paris c'est
paris quoi à l'époque
le rêve c'était une chose avec tc
c'était autre chose un autre métier
faisons
donc à risque en yougoslavie on connaît
le mouvement de libération de la femme
c'est maintenant le genre ville et les
gens filles qui sont mariés tous à
travailler se sentent plus libres comme
les femmes qui s'étaient mariés d'autant
que je travaillais pas fédérales 2011
liberté que les banques françaises dans
un sens ou à la contraception par
exemple l'éducation sexuelle est bien
fait pour les femmes les jeunes filles
si c'est très bien peut-être mais qui
sait peut-être parce qu'ils avaient tous
dit oui parce qu'il ya certaines choses
qui sont autorisés les gens filles que
ici c'est
peut-être cjmcq et qu'ils paient pas la
loi qui fait qui est adapté la loi qui
permet pas catherine
qui ne permet pas mais se noue oui oui
ce que vous pratiquez la contraception
pas trop
pourquoi parce que vous ne connaissez
pas bien parce que c'est contre vos
principes ou ben
j'sais pas ça ne vient pas dans l'idiot
face à me
je pense même pas voyez vous ce que vous
pensez que vos compatriotes en ont
connaissance oui elles en ont
connaissance de la contraception de
l'éducation sexuelle elles connaissent
ou pas du tout en suisse un type en fait
je ne peux pas vous le dire je ne sais
pas si vous pensez pas que c'est quelque
chose d'important s'il est ce que vous
connaissez le moyen pour éviter d'avoir
des enfants
la méthode médicale non
c'est arrivé j'étais vraiment déçu
complètement déçu mais au début au début
mais petit à petit
c'était la
journée
oui bien trop brouillonne avec un souris
avec un sourire
avec beaucoup de promesses
avec
bradley c'est votre nom
et pas de réponse
sur le curé éducation sur le plan
religieux comment élever vous cathy
à ne pas dire pendant deux ans donc ce
n'est le même pâté e
légion
et les coutumes et ce que vous essayez
de lui faire conserver puisqu'elle est
là pas qu'elle connaît très peu la
yougoslavie
si on parle avec elle hugo slave c'est
déjà une chose et puis on part tous les
années votre vie en expliquant mener la
barque et elle
initie mais tout même elle n'est pas
remboursable
où
doux
la commande squatté
par des petites sommes
super
[Musique]
vous êtes divorcer vous vivez tout seul
avec votre petit garçon c'est difficile
ah oui ça c'est vrai c'est un peu
difficile vous êtes mariée avec un
portugais oui que vous avez connu en
france oui s'il est de la même ville que
moi mais moi je n'ai pas que mur
portugais ici et maintenant il est parti
c'est parti au canada parce qu'il vous
aide pour le petit nom il était obligé
pour des pensionnats obligé devenu une
passion mais quand eli qui s'il n'a
donné safran tout le mois il est parti
marion me
j'avais trouvé du travail facilement
arrive enfin si
j'arrivais en france j'ai trouvé du
travail dans une boulangerie
mais j'ai pas rester longtemps
c'est la famille au jt holmes radio
c'est pas bien payé tout ça se trouve
notre place j'ai laissé la boulangerie
j'ai trouvé de ménage dans un bureau du
matin au soir mais j'y croyais tout de
suite qui est c'est plus dur que la
boulangerie si je me lève de bonne heure
et tout ça mais ça fait le papier après
ça j'ai parlé pour travailler dans
l'industrie à boulogne je travaille à
l'un des jeunes mariés
après quand j'ai mauricie l'essai de
travail
est ce que vous faites c'est dur
si c'est un peu difficile lui tarde de
voir geffroy là mais
je travaillerai toujours d'être bien
gentille la grille je travaille ça me
fait
juste ni ça me passe bien a ajouté ce
n'est pas tendu qui crée un rail bien
avec déjà qu'ils sont jeunes technique
et j'ai pas
[Musique]
j'ai ma soeur qui habite à côté de moi
un simple mais de me lever le matin même
rôle chez elle je parte pour mon travail
puis à me garder le mineur école est la
chercher et quand j'arrive à le chercher
chez ma soeur car tout va je dîne chez
des engagements et udine chez moi avec
mon fils
c'est tout
[Musique]
vous êtes arrivés ensemble votre
serez-vous arménien j arrivais un
effet masse à l'arrivée deux années pour
moi c'est ma mère qui me l'a qu'a voulu
que je parte avec mme pour racheter les
trois soeurs parce qu'elle est mais il
est tout seul ici en france
vous n'envisagez pas du tout de
retourner dans votre pays un jour n'ont
pas tout de suite j'aime pas quand tu
peux pas parce que ici
je travaille je gagne un peu le sam ça
me suffit pour moi et mon fils est pas
je n'aime pas tellement bien mais
c'est juste mais tout même j'arrive à
vivre avec mon fils vous pensez toujours
rester en france vous pensez
je pense à pelé tony et moi je me suis
dit à vivre dans ces rentrées
oui c'est tout va bien
ouais j'ai pas toujours donné six mois
pour moi je ne pense pas mais c'est
possible pour le moment je ne pense pas
je pense que l'avenir de négoce ça
dépend
mais franchement on n'a pas très bien
réussi ça mais
sûrement un jour peut-être ça sera
difficile parce que la petite a ses
habitués elle appelait habitude essayé
elle à ses copines c'est comme à l'école
ça sûrement plus difficile incomplète
heures
mais personnellement je voudrais bien
manger des oeufs nuit quand je suis
énervé janabi dupré neymar ali zamani en
temps de guerre et c'est en france que
vous avez connu votre mari mais comment
ça se fait que on se marrait presque
toujours entre gens de même pays
là c'est normal
mais pourquoi vous êtes tenus en france
beaucoup de la nuit
il avait
pas peur c'était mes poissons d'armé
c'est pas possible il faut être clair
mais c'est la glace et tout va
bien ou pas d'accord cela va finir
voilà je sais pas
je n'ai que cinq ans
j'avais déjà mais chaque page va
chercher je pense à au concert j'achète
petite chose pour ma femme
adore jeunes etc 53 et c'est très bon
pour lui
moi
la nourriture bio
[Musique]
j'ai mon fils lui ça va je suis content
avec lui mais
je suis triste quand même
monsieur et madame vous êtes en france
depuis longtemps oui mais c'est un point
de pris et les 15 avril 63 si vous
faites comme travail avant au départ et
c'était mon oeuvre j'ai fait six mois à
marseille
je suis venu à paris sa vie d'avant à
cachan tu veux la voir si les nazis suis
venu dans le 15e arrondissement paris
croix nivert je vais presque six ans la
voir vous étiez tout seul je vous ai vu
directement avec votre femme non j'étais
tout seul et vous l'avez fait venir
après oui
si si
exemple monsieur comment cette lan bouge
bien sûr
très très oui trop peu quand vous
travaillez vous même qu'est ce que vous
faites c'est herman analyser comment
vous faites pour votre petit garçon
alors qu'est-ce qui s'en occupe quand
vous travaillez
ça coûte cher eh oui
très peu d'entre vous vivre en famille
beaucoup sont dans des foyers la
province dispose enfin il veut tout
salisien j'ai pas une victoire mais
seulement ils n'ont pas de moyens
ils n'ont pas de moyens j'ai vous avez
bien voulu répondre à nos questions et
vous souhaitez ne pas apparaître à
l'écran est ce que je peux vous demander
pourquoi
parce que vous savez mademoiselle que
chacun doit protéger son avenir tout en
essayant de se méfier de cette chose
vous craignez que l'on puisse vous faire
grief de ce que vous avez à dire
vous êtes en france depuis combien de
temps monsieur je suis en france depuis
1967 dans quelles circonstances est ce
que vous êtes venus je suis venu en
clandestin tu le reconnais je suis marié
j'ai des enfants je les oui combien 6 au
säntis ils sont à l'abri qu est-ce que
c'est difficile à supporter cette
solitude
très difficile mais il faut la patience
ce n'est pas difficile pour un père de
famille d'être séparé de ses enfants
comme ça bien sûr chaque personne peut
se placer comme moi verra bien comment
ça fait mal je ne suis pas heureux si
loin de mes enfants mais je suis obligé
de me déplacer pour les besoins de la
famille est ce assez pour une saison pas
pour toujours
je vis aux collectivités avec les
camarades que j'ai trouvée avant moi
et qui sol dans les foyers
des fois une pierre loger ou encore des
fois mal logés
nous avons intérêt à rester groupés nous
avons souvent des enfants qui n'ont pas
l'habitude des capitales qui sont
obligés de se lever un tout petit peu
l'est pas pour les mettre sur le bon
chemin et les empêchait aussi à ne pas
aller contre certaines autorités pour
dégrader quand même notre situation en
france actuellement je fais le balayeur
de la rue
henri iv
en serrant la ceinture oui et en pense a
les enfants
je n'ai aucun niveau d'instruction
je le regrettais parce que ici
actuellement en france et je n'ai pas
une certaine l'instruction pour me
permettre la cession à cet objectif dans
mon pays où aussi si si j'étais bien
instruits je pouvais avoir autre chose
que de voyager comme l'oiseau vous
pensez pas rester toujours ici au nom
sali lefrançois je souhaite pas aux
oubliettes
ah oui presque je vous dis on est
beaucoup malheureux nous faisons pas
trop mais on est malheureux ici bas
non parce que certains soucis on s'en
parle de coût de la politique on n'est
pas trop aimé voir
tous les ans des couleurs nous on n'est
pas trop aimé un
nom
la nourrice qui s'occupe du petit petit
garçon il garde d'autres enfants
et c'est une dame noire c'est une
ambiance et une française oui elle est
gentil avec le sentez
vous avez des amis français n'avaient
commis ni de manger un sénégalais pas du
tout à me françois roux
pourquoi pas
n'est ce pas aussi tout est possible
dans la vie quand on veut pour moi tout
le monde et par evo j'ai beaucoup voyagé
ce fric avec plusieurs un désert as plus
rien de la vilaine habitude comme ça va
signer comme ça tout le monde est pareil
pour moi
très difficile
pourquoi
c'est dur à trouver pour nous
après ce que je vous dis moi de police
c'est presque un poulet racines ou voit
pas ça va admettons aussi on voit une
annonce dans un journal et un millier de
pièces livre comme ça si on téléphone si
je téléphone banlieues dont je parle
bien le français avoir appelé ne peut
pas connaître si c'est la voix des noirs
ne s'est pas dit waouh pour venir dès
qu'on se présente des cas soit vraiment
il dit qu'à laisser la grèce id a pris
parce que c'est difficile d'être des
travailleurs immigrés
oui c'est difficile parce qu'il faut il
s'habille tout est un c'est pas
tellement facile au début on connaît pas
les gens
mais bon on a on a travaillé avec des
gens qui après dans la maison était très
gentil et qui après vous heurtez dans la
rue et vous vous le trouvez personne
vous parle ce que vous faites une
différence vous entre les algériens et
les français
c'est à dire ça c'est difficile à vous
répondre parce que je suis allé chez des
algériens en fait j'ai déconné ce qu'ils
sont très très bien qui a d'autres bien
sûr que sans
enfin qu'ils sont pas vraiment peut-être
exemple des moyens peut-être les
français comment sont prises avec vous
quand il chantait centrale gentilly rien
dire jamais aucun problème parce que
vous êtes étrangères non pas du tout
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'à
l'étranger a plus de difficulté qu'un
français a trouvé du travail à trouver
un solution du tout pas du tout si je
dit non
au geste est difficile parce qu'on parle
pas la langue c'est déjà oui mais déjà
conduit par le moment mon dieu je pars
en français ou étrangers 20
propriétaires avaient besoin locataires
baril prendre n'importe qui polar
étrangers en france et c'est pareil pour
moi c'est pareil je suis pas d'accord
certaines
propriétaire que vous même pas étranger
de leur trajet vous aime pas le noir
quoi il ya cette avocate a vécu
en france quand on pense aux africains
c'est à dire noir ou algériens marocains
tunisiens c'est à dire enfin arabe on
pense étrangers et moi je crois que là
intervient le racisme qui existe qui est
qui est indéniable qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
ce contact de la situation et puis il ya
les labels sol parce que plus on dit
plus on est mal vu
mais au fond de vous qu'est ce que vous
ressentez je sens bien que je suis à
l'étranger pas été chez moi si on
m'avait dit que c'est par les français
ils peuvent se comporter d'une manière
pareil je l'aurais pas cru
mais maintenant que ces lois - lacroix
très bizarre mais appel à moi je
voudrais dire quelque chose par rapport
au racisme je crois il vient aussi en
particulier pour notre quartier du fait
qu'il ya une trop forte densité de
travailleurs immigrés dans une école
lorsqu on retrouvera le pourcentage de 2
50 à 60 % d'enfants immigrés ce qui veut
dire dans le quartier il ya une
population de 30 à 40% enfin la limite
ce n'est pas vivable et c'est à leur mal
il faudrait et des études ont été faites
dans ce sens il faudrait qu'il y ait un
minimum d'enfants immigrés pour que
l'intégration se fasse mieux v et haut
niveau sur le pont scolaire et sur le
plan du quartier
le petit enfant quand ils arrivent à
l'école il n'est pas raciste mais je
crois qu'il le devient parce qu'à
l'école il revit et le redis skins crier
ce qui est vécu dans la famille dans le
cahier automatiquement autres enfants
des réactions racistes
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiter pour vos
enfants ne sont pas obligés d'émigrer
si ce projet vous ne souhaitez pas
pareil que moi
à google c'est que je ne souhaite pas
qui sera comme moi il ce qui sera
beaucoup mieux que moi
on souhaite toujours enfin qui sera le
meilleur qu'on me fasse mes enfants
quand ils seront grands
si n'est pas moi que je vais les
conseillers se soit qu'ils soient
algériens en france incitant à choisir
ce que vous souhaitez pour vos enfants
aux grands livres à leur plaisir et puis
essayer de se faire une situation si
j'arrive à denver
mais vachement de lui
tomber sur la glace ça serait arrivé à
choisir voit pas et venez à paris xviie
après ce que vous accepteriez ou est ce
que vous seriez content qu'elle épousa
français qu'elle fasse à vis en france
je
sais pas du tout à ça
et c'est pour ça elle va déposer un
nombre qui veulent me
caty non politiquement s'ils ont vu que
tu veux rester en france soit tu fais
rentrer en effet cela dit
comme tu veux rester en france où tu
veux retourner en espagne
en espagne on y lit halal plage et j en
a pas
c'est sur ces images d'enfants souriants
que nous allons prendre congé de vous
souhaitons seulement qu'il conserve tout
au long de leur vie ce visage détendu
qu'ils aient le choix de leur destin et
pour reprendre le désir commun de leurs
parents qu'ils vivent mieux que
je souhaite que vous passiez une
excellente fin de journée je vous dis à
bientôt pour un autre aujourd'hui madame
[Musique]